hello and welcome this video plank am
stefan off no name maybe really is
called Stefan off it's probably a
relatively frequent payment will Gary up
which is the flag here right bulgaria
okay so and some old Indian Kings Indian
kind of position besides now g6 is the
Kings Indian this is the old Indian with
the bishop only seven and what seems he
has a pretty bad connection rupee
eight-year couple of options I usually
go for d5 and those positions taking the
space in the center
yeah 92 g6 possibly to f4 yeah a couple
of regrouping white can go for 2d to to
have night to D to lie to d3 and going
for the 93 route here this also covers f
foursquare quite reliably mm-hmm so
what's the deal here you want to play a
5 no matter what is probably the deal
okay yeah I actually wanted to invite
that so okay I could have played g3
maybe he might still have neither for
now as a porn Sackman you know ok it's
mean it's not if it's not a big deal per
se
okay so
I mean training some stuffy is helpful
for black but I still don't think I'm in
a big and big issues him so got some
good space maybe it's got something with
a five year no he goes for this one okay
you
this feels kind of comfortable for watch
or am I wrong yeah Wow it just takes it
Wow hmm yeah this just looks very nice
for white the batter bishop only three
more space threat on c6 mmm it's got a
pretty awful lack so if i take this he's
giving me porn so what it's going to be
pawns I think I'm taking them okay I can
take on d6 I can take on c6 is there
anything here's this check on III this
looks better
okay so maybe just a 5 protect this
protects be four but also protect the
rook so on Rue create I have a
convenient rookie one yet this I didn't
see what I can take here threatening 25
or threatening is probably strong to
strand word but intending a rupee
warning else but think this one then
push the sea por all the thread you
create with made so
ok now it's no mate unfortunately this
is six though I complain open up
blundering some stuff yet looks kind of
tricky we may even show all this
maybe I had something that was somewhat
clearer I don't know but see seven is a
I mean it's a big threat maybe he simply
has no defense to it
and I don't see a move for black can
check here King edge one but what's the
shayateen uation if he goes rook c8 are
still places seven okay yeah let's let's
just prevent any background stuff and
now air Queen d5 it still might check
out clinking g5 something like that
ruckus MLS's check
385 it shakes now we play screen g5
immediately probably with account with
them calendar ideas okay I'll just ask
him for move him now walk the seven as
an idea and screen c5 is no check if you
move the Queen somewhere here on g five
or so then fc7 rook c8 I have 25 more
power up dis have knocked assemblers
actually stronger and then c7 next
ook c5 rope t8 trade trade I nice that's
this dark squared I would you have
probably been on time him one last four
fits on time I always said to connection
issues him um yeah some some surprising
decisions here this is certainly a
theoretical position and probably the
still yeah white has more space that is
a bit better but it isn't something
serious f3 is probably a move that I
should not play yet I don't need to play
or allow him to play nine age five okay
now this I cannot win the window porn
here if we look at this this is not a
very nice position first of all blank is
able to draw immediately but the second
thing is he doesn't have to know you can
just play this position with his good
dark squares not quite sure how them
yeah it's unattractive for white 22 the
perpetual anyway and there was surprised
that he that he played like that to be
honest and then if five and I took it
the engine wants to do this with a big
advantage maybe I definitely have a
better development him okay this
happened but I was very surprised that
he took the noid i was thinking queen d
7 or whatever just something else it's
after the capture you just jared is
better for forever and here he gave me
that pawn after which white is
objectively speaking winning but you
still catcher I have to win it check
HERE computer likes my play route 27 it
gives us a total win now yes hmm because
he cannot take the 60 to the back room
mate but I think I don't think I spoiled
anything no this is
actually pretty decent play and after
this I am completely winning and here i
think the check should that should do
the trick check c7 it's gone chest check
check check check King f1 here is
probably shouting out or check someone
check on g6 King edge to and I'm getting
a new queen yeah some surprising
decisions they especially to take on you
for this is just giving Y teacher yeah
completely uncontested advantage that
black should definitely avoid this move
okay well thanks for watching